PENNSYLVANIA AND AMERICANS
DESERVE TOTAL TRANSPARENCY.
A LIFTEST JUDGE IN VIRGINIA HAS
JUST TOSSED A REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE FOR THE BALLOT EVEN
THOUGH EARLY VOTING IS UNDER WAY
AND THE PRIMARY IS DAYS AWAY.
THE JUDGE RULED THAT VOTES FOR
DISTRICT SENATE CANDIDATE ANDREA
GARRETT WOULD NOT BE COUNTED
DOWN TO ISSUES OVER HER
RESIDENCY.
IMMEDIATELY SIGNS WERE POSTED AT
POLLING PLACES ANNOUNCING THAT
SHE'S INELIGIBLE.
BUT SHE'S FIGHTING BACK SAYING
SHE ALWAYS HAS BEEN A WEST
VIRGINIAN AND THIS IS
DISENFRANCHISING TO THE VOTERS.
THE CANDIDATE MADE AN APPEAL TO
THE SUPREME COURT TO PUT A STAY
ON THE JUDGE'S RULING.
HOURS AGO THEY REJECTED THAT
MOTION.
JOINING US NOW IS GOP STATES
SENATE CANDIDATE ANDREA AND HER
CAMPAIGN SPOKESMAN.
YOUR APPEAL WAS REJECTED FOR THE
STAY.
VOTING IS UNDERWAY.
WHERE DOES YOUR FIGHT GO FROM
HERE?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING US ON,
LAURA.
WE'RE DISAPPOINTED BY THE
SUPREME COURT'S RULING TODAY.
IT'S JUST DISAPOINTSING.
WE HAVE A LOT OF EXPECTATIONS IN
TERMS OF THE INTEGRITY OF
ELECTIONS AND THE FACT THAT
THERE WAS A JUDGE THAT
INTERFERED WITH OUR CANDIDACY.
>> Laura: WHAT'S GOING ON?
YOU HAVE A CAMPAIGN MANAGER
SITTING NEXT TO YOU THAT WOULD
ANTICIPATE EVERYTHING, RIGHT?
LIKE THE CAMPAIGN MANAGER, YOU
HAVE TO -- THIS ROAD BLOCK COULD
COME, THIS OBSTACLE COULD COME.
WHEN THE VOTING IS ALREADY
UNDERWAY, HOW IS THIS IN ANY WAY
COMMON SENSE BESIDE THE LEGAL
ISSUES INVOLVED?
>> YEAH, THAT'S IT, LAURA.
OBVIOUSLY WE KNEW -- ANDREA
SPLIT TIME BETWEEN HERE AND
ANOTHER STATE OVER A FEW YEARS.
THERE'S A WINDOW TO CHALLENGE
THIS STUFF.
ONCE WE GOT THROUGH THAT WINDOW,
WE REALLY STEPPED ON THE GAS ON
THE CAMPAIGN.
WHAT TRIGGERED THIS CHALLENGE IS
WE HAVE ONE OF HER OPPONENTS, A
LIBERAL CANDIDATE.
HE WAS THE ONLY REPUBLICAN TO
SUPPORT THE TRANSGENDER ISSUE
STUFF HERE IN WEST VIRGINIA.
ONCE HE TOOK A POLL AND FOUND
OUT THAT ANDREA WAS IN FIRST AND
HE WAS IN LAST, HE BUDDIED UP
WITH THE LOCAL GREEDY PERSONAL
INJURY LAWYERS AND THE LOCAL
LIBERAL ACTIVIST JUDGE AND GOT
HER THROWN OFF THE BALLOT.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE A STATE
SUPREME COURT REFUSAL TO
INTERVENE AS WELL.
AND YET WHEN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
VOTE, IS YOUR NAME ON THE BALLOT
OR NO?
>> MY NAME IS ON THE BALLOT.
IT'S STILL THERE.
THERE'S SIGNS IN SOME PRECINCTS
THAT HAVE INDICATED MY
INELIGIBILITY.
MY NAME IS STALE ON THE BALLOT
AND MANY PEOPLE HAVE SAID
THEY'RE GOING TO BE VOTING FOR
ME.
>> Laura: WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU
GET THE MOST VOTES?
THEY'RE GOING TO THROW THAT OUT
TOO, RIGHT, GREG?
>> YEAH, ESSENTIALLY THE JUDGE
RULED THAT THEY WON'T COUNT HER
VOTES.
SO SHE -- THE MOST RECENT
POLLING WE HAVE, SHE WAS GETTING
OVER 50% IN A FOUR-WAY RACE.
SO ESSENTIALLY THE MINORITY OF
VOTERS WILL BE SPLIT -- THE
MAJORITY OF THE MINORITY OF
VOTERS WILL GET TO PICK SOME
LIBERAL REPUBLICAN TO GET BEAT
BY THE DEMOCRAT IN THE FALL.
>> Laura: THE CONCERN IS THAT
YOU'RE WHAT?
YOU'RE A RESIDENT IN TWO
DIFFERENT STATES OR SPENT TOO
MUCH TIME IN ANOTHER STATE TO BE
ELIGIBLE?
>> CORRECT.
I MOVED TO NORTH CAROLINA AND
SPENT TIME THERE.
I SPLIT MY TIME BETWEEN
NORTH CAROLINA, MINNESOTA AND
WEST VIRGINIA.
SO YEAH, THAT WAS THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM.
NOW OF COURSE IN WEST VIRGINIA,
ONE OF OUR MAIN CONCERNS IS
RETENTION OF TALENT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
DO, BRING PEOPLE BACK TO WEST
VIRGINIA.
MY TIME SPENT IN OTHER STATES
WAS A MEANS TO AN END, TO RETURN
TO WEST VIRGINIA.
SO I'M DISAPPOINTED.
BUT THERE'S STILL A LOT OF WORK
TO DO.
>> Laura: ANDREA AND GREG,
THANKS FOR COMING.
ANDREA, YOU JUST HAVE TO GET
BACK AT IT.
OKAY?
DON'T LET THIS STOP YOU.
THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP TRYING TO
DO STUFF LIKE THIS, I IMAGINE.
BUT RUN AGAIN IF TH